Guyane terre ancestral des Amérindiens
[Musique]
qui veille sur son peuple
quand il y a quelque chose qui va pas
on tourne vers lui pour discuter comment
on va faire comment il faut faire et
comment ne pas faire
et celui qui est le porte-parole du
village des habitants
Cécile est bien dans son travail le
message de l'intelligent et le bâton
[Musique]
il fait un travail mais vraiment
travaille formidable au niveau de la
culture
de l'artisanat aussi
c'est une grande dame au broker tout ce
qu'elle fait tout ce qu'elle fera dans
sa vie ce sera toujours pour son peuple
dans son village
je suis Cécile
chef du village de Bellevue la première
chef femme
chez les kaliniens
coincé entre le Brésil et le Suriname la
Guyane ce morceau de terre français
d'Amazonie est une incroyable mosaïque
de peuple
créole bouchina gay chinois brésilien
sur une Amiens européenne haïtien
sicotoie depuis des siècles
[Musique]
mais les premiers habitants ce sont les
Amérindiens
installés sur ce territoire depuis le 5e
siècle avant notre ère ils étaient
environ 30 000 à l'arrivée des premiers
Européens
l'esclavagisme la ruée vers l'or et les
maladies ont décimé ces peuples qui ne
représentent aujourd'hui plus que 5% de
la population guyanaise
autrefois nomades la majeure partie
d'entre eux c'est sédentarisés on compte
5 villages au nord-ouest de Cayenne
[Musique]
comme ici à Bellevue sur la commune
d'irakubo ou plus de 600 Amérindiens se
battent pour défendre leurs droits et
leur tradition
à leur tête
Cécile couyori descendante du peuple
kalinha
[Musique]
le 7 juillet 1997 investie par la
Fédération des organisations des peuples
autochtones de Guyane elle devient la
première femme chef coutumière de son
village
cécile couyori a alors 38 ans et son
combat ne fait que commencer
pour être
un peuple et un village qui n'ont cessé
d'évoluer
le village de Bellevue n'était pas un
village au début alors le premier
monsieur qui est venu s'installer
justement à la recherche de la bonne
personne mon papa lui dire que Yuri
le papa mère indien était un peuple
nomade
et on se déplaçait et on s'installait
les parents s'installaient près d'une
rivière
mes parents ont vécu dans le village
gros roche c'est là que je suis né
à l'époque les familles vivaient sous
des carbets habitat traditionnels
Amérindiens fait de bois deux feuilles
et de lianes ils se font aujourd'hui de
plus en plus rares
je suis née sous un carbet déjà
le placent a été enterré sous un carbet
à l'époque puisqu'on connaissait pas
l'hôpital à l'époque et j'ai vécu dans
sous un café à côté de mes parents et ça
c'est ma vie à moi et ça fait ma fierté
et c'est cette fierté qui a toujours
porté ses cils
transmission du savoir c'est pas comme
ça qu'on pourra transmettre le savoir à
nos enfants depuis 25 ans Cécile se bat
pour défendre sa communauté
[Musique]
de jouer avec la venir de nos enfants
obtenir plus de terre pour son peuple
est un de ses combats
en 2019 l'État lui octroie 1000 hectares
pour y développer les abattis
Amérindiens des parcelles de culture
individuelles
d'autres familles la nouvelle génération
s'installe qu'il s'installe
en premier pour le rabattis et faire le
un lieu de vie un lieu de vie qui
peut-être améliorée au fil des années
parce que quand on est on a une
concession collective au fil des années
ça peut devenir session
pour convaincre les jeunes Amérindiens
de s'installer ici cécile a organisé une
rencontre avec Aloïs
Anita et Suzette les premiers à avoir
acceptés de cultiver une parcelle sur ce
nouveau territoire
[Musique]
Béatrice c'est tout ce qu'il y a comme
monde ah bon quand on a invité des gens
surtout des jeunes
c'est dommage pourtant c'est très
important une rencontre dans justement
dans la concession où habite Anita ça
serait bien d'en parler surtout de voir
on va faire ça comme d'habitude
Béatrice c'est la seule à avoir répondu
à l'appel de Cécile cultiver la terre
comme leurs ancêtres avant eux n'est
plus forcément la préoccupation des
jeunes Amérindiens
et pour vos enfants et que la maison
reste vide la bâtisse a besoin vitale
pour notre vie pour la nourriture moi je
vois les choses comme ça c'est pas parce
que tu seras peut-être un docteur de
même que demain tu peux pas faire un
abatti tu peux parler à la chasse tu
peux parler à la pêche puisque ça fait
partie de notre vie c'est notre richesse
nos valeurs
et cette concession là c'était c'est
vraiment pour le but d'agrandir un petit
peu le village pour que la jeunesse
justement s'installe petit à petit
alors comment ils font les jeunes
[Rires]
pistache maïs
citron tout pousse ici
le rêve de Cécile c'est que chaque
amérindien de sa communauté puisse vivre
de ses cultures et deviennent
autosuffisants pour lui et sa famille
pour manger pas pour revendre plein pour
manger donc il y a très peu de quantités
qui est plantée puisque c'est pour eux
ça c'est des graines d'Awa
et avec ça on va faire le
fil tout ça le met dans une casserole et
l'huile monte puisque Laura il y a de
l'huile et le résultat c'est ça ce qu'on
appelle le tchou-tchou ça c'est un
médicament pour qu'on se blesse c'est ça
l'huile de Marie paille également je
vais aller faire la maison pour moi
parce qu'il me disent que c'est pas les
boutons les blessures pour masser la
nature je vais le fabriquer à la maison
et montrer où pour plus tard
nous devons assurer l'avenir de la
nouvelle génération qui vient vous voyez
parce que sur la terre ils vont pas
vivre où est-ce qu'ils vont s'installer
où est-ce qu'ils vont s'installer on a
de la terre donc c'est pour cette
génération qui est là la nouvelle
génération qui suit qui suivront
voilà moi je pense que j'ai fait mon
travail de chef c'était le plus gros
combat c'était le combat de la terre
à cela s'ajoute pour la chef une autre
mission
maintenir les traditions
au cœur du village la cérémonie des
becodonos le lever de deuil est sur le
point de démarrer
en hommage à un villageois disparu il y
a trois ans sa famille et une grande
partie du village se sont rassemblés
le cashiri boisson traditionnelle à base
de manioc et de pommes de terre douces
fermentées elle distribué de mains en
main
Cécile se prépare elle aussi pour la
cérémonie
elle revêt pour l'occasion sa tenue
traditionnelle languissa
dans quelques minutes elle va prononcer
le discours d'ouverture des célébrations
24 sur 24
je pense que à chaque fois que je mets
mes tenues je suis une autre Cécile mais
carrément dans son monde à elle
Gon et le bonhomme
que ce magasin
ce soir c'est des condolants qui se fait
ça fait partie de notre costume
ancestral je dirais c'est une manière de
se séparer définitivement du défunt et
une fois si c'est une femme qui est mort
le mari après pourra se remarier et la
femme pourra également se remarier c'est
c'est ce que ça signifie
[Musique]
les chansons qu'on écoute là c'est
vraiment la vie de la personne en lui
dit de revenir justement pour qu'on le
fasse danser même si on le voit pas
c'est spirituel on le fait danser pour
qu'il soit demain heureux de partir
définitivement
[Musique]
mon père s'appelle
tout le monde est là pour lui parce que
tout le monde le connaissait peut-être
qu'il nous regarde peut-être qu'il danse
aussi avec nous
j'ai plus de papa
il regarde il est là avec nous il danse
avec nous il est heureux là
au petit matin un feu est allumé
quelques effets personnels du défunt ils
sont brûlés
[Musique]
entreprend son dernier voyage
les cendres sont piétinés
symbole de la victoire de la vie sur
l'esprit responsable de la mort
la veuve et ses enfants peuvent
maintenant être purifiés
[Musique]
à cette occasion là on fait pousser
vraiment les cheveux pendant plusieurs
années et quand le jour arrive pour que
on dise carrément adieu à se défaire on
coupe les cheveux au gardera le sang
souvenir qu'il a vécu parmi nous qu'il a
été le papa de garçon des filles le mari
de Jacqueline
[Musique]
il y a une partie qui est triste parce
que les choses c'est un peu triste ça
fait très score non et après
et après la tristesse on est joyeuse
cette cérémonie religieuse on sera uni
uni une hypo toujours
le deuil est terminé la veuve est
désormais libre
[Musique]
c'est vrai que avec la modernité le
moine qui change nous avons tendance à
tout perdre mais ce rituel là qui est
spirituelle qui est qui est ancestral il
est très important de le faire
aujourd'hui au village
l'une des meilleures confidents de
Cécile c'est sa cousine Marie son
caractère
quand elle est
un petit mide un peu c'est moi qui
bouscule un tout petit peu
je veux me débrouiller et bien des fois
moi ça m'énerve je lui dis mais tant pis
pour toi mais moi je te laisse je
t'abandonne bon après je me reprends sur
moi j'ai dit ah pourquoi j'ai dit ça
j'ai dit je suis partant
ça y est elle est protégée
et on est bien c'est ma cousine préférée
et pourtant elle a des sœurs
[Rires]
je me souviens un jour elle était dans
mon hamac pour m'embêter
chez moi je me rappelle plus de ça hein
je savais que c'était elle j'ai pris le
bord du hameau j'ai soulevé et puis
après je lui arraché un brin de cheveux
devant pas un prénom
c'était tout nu
troisième d'une fratrie de 11 enfants et
première fille la chef coutumière a été
éduquée selon les préceptes de la
tradition et de la culture amérindienne
une conception de l'éducation que ne
partageait pas Cécile la rebelle de la
famille au grand désespoir de ses
parents
je voulais faire exactement tout ce que
les hommes faisaient et ça plaisait pas
trop à mon papa parce que la fille
devait rester à sa place le garçon à sa
place
et d'ailleurs très tôt je voulais être
indépendante je voulais faire mon Carbet
j'avais déjà commencé mon papa n'était
pas contente du tout du tout les parents
n'ont pas été à l'école ils n'ont pas eu
le temps d'aller à l'école mais j'étais
quand même très heureux que les enfants
aillent justement à prendre à l'école
[Musique]
Sina Marie deuxième plus grande commune
de l'Ouest guyanais
à 40 km du village de Bellevue
au milieu du siècle dernier le
gouvernement français impose aux
familles amérindiennes de scolariser
leurs enfants dans des institutions
religieuses
couverts
[Musique]
moi j'ai fait première maternelle
deuxième troisième ou CP jusqu'au CM2
ici
c'est vrai avec la cloche qui sonnait
fondé en 1949 l'homme catholique de
cinnamary est aujourd'hui totalement
délabrée pendant plus de 30 ans cette
internat a vu des centaines de jeunes
filles amérindiennes se succédaient
parmi elles Cécile et pascalines une
amitié née sous la tutelle stricte et
obligatoire des sœurs Franciscaines moi
je suis venu ici à la rue de trois ans
et puis en fait pour apprendre à écrire
et à lire parce que à l'époque les
parents ne pouvaient pas vraiment il y
avait pas d'école sur le village et puis
bien sûr
nous ont pris si on peut dire ça chez
les parents pour venir ici petit nous
avons grandi chez les soeurs jusqu'à
l'âge de 12 ans il y avait une petite
salle où la supérieure aussi vers les
filles qui avaient désobéis
et la punition chez moi on m'avait fait
la punition m'avait donné la puis
c'était du pain du pain sec et de l'eau
c'est toujours été gentil
on verra bien ce qu'ils vont faire de ce
bâtiment là quoi j'espère qu'ils vont
faire quelque chose de bien quand même
je pense qu'ils vont carrément le cancer
pour faire du neuf est-ce que ils
peuvent plus faire grand chose toi et
dégradé maintenant voilà toi tu as dormi
là oui j'ai dormi là si je suis venue
devenue la femme que je suis maintenant
c'est peut-être grâce à eux qui m'ont
donné une bonne une bonne éducation
oh là là
oh mon dieu
ça c'est
ah ouais
c'est donc
[Musique]
une éducation qui a toutefois participé
à la disparition de certaines traditions
autochtones
mais elle a permis aussi à Cécile et son
ami de découvrir une autre culture
c'est dans ces murs qu'elles ont appris
à coudre jardiner et cuisiner à
l'occidental
un nouveau mode de vie auquel elles ont
dû s'habituer
on reparta chez nous pour les vacances
qu'un jour les grandes vacances de mois
et on revenait bien sûr avec le cœur
serré imaginez-vous dès l'âge de 6 ans
il coupure familiale pendant trois mois
c'est quelque chose
nous devrions concilier la vie à
l'internat
avec la vie
l'éducation chez nos parents la vie
aussi de notre vie aussi communautaire
et avec les deux villes là c'est vrai
que on mélange quand on est adolescent
et c'est après qu'il faut vraiment faire
le tri de ce qu'on a pris on a appris
ailleurs et ce qu'on a aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir concilier les deux moi je vois
le j'ai vu les choses comme ça je vois
les choses aujourd'hui comme ça toujours
l'opportunité de quitter quelques heures
le pensionnat n'avait lu qu'une fois par
semaine
l'évangélisation au cœur de l'éducation
à façonner de nombreuses générations
[Musique]
c'est ici que tous les dimanches nous
venions à la messe je me revois petite
fille avec ma belle robe belle chaussure
de dimanche et puis on allait s'asseoir
par là avec toutes les autres et puis on
prenait paramètres aux différentes
la lecture rocher parfois et c'était une
joie une joie de partage avec les autres
les autres personnes qui venaient à la
messe voilà après le CM2 les jeunes
amérindiennes devaient rejoindre un
autre internat
là une éducation plus dure plus stricte
a forgé le caractère de ces femmes
d'aujourd'hui elles n'ont pas eu d'autre
choix que s'adapter et trouver comment
concilier deux cultures parfois très
différentes à l'Internet de parler le
kalinyan ni le créole on parlait que le
français c'est une obligation parce que
je m'étais fait attirée un jour mes
cheveux par une sœur qui m'avait surpris
en train de parler en créole
on pouvait pas parler le français avec
nos parents puisque je comprenais pas à
l'époque et il y a quelque chose qu'on
rajoutait dans notre vie communautaire
dans nos villages c'est que par exemple
les fêtes de Noël l'arbre de Noël un
bouquet pour pour une maman pour la fête
des mères comme c'est pas dans nos
coutumes donc il comprenait pas tu
offres un bouquet de fleurs chose que
j'avais fait un moment bonjour
je dis tiens un bouquet de fleurs pour
ta fête elle m'avait dit mais est-ce que
c'est ce que tu vois pour mon frère
j'avais oublié ça c'est pour ça que
c'est un peu difficile de prendre dans
la vie
occidentale qu'on vivait et de le
ramener chez nous parce qu'il y avait
vraiment c'était deux vies différentes
et c'est je pense que après c'est devenu
c'est rentré petit à petit tout
doucement sans même qu'on se rende
compte dans notre vie communautaire
désormais les home catholiques
appartiennent au passé
pour les enfants de Bellevue plus
question de quitter leur village
[Musique]
avec la volonté de Cécile est le soutien
de la population une école maternelle a
vu le jour
[Musique]
ici les cultures se mêlent désormais
harmonieusement plusieurs fois par
semaine comme un pied né à l'ancien
temps
c'est en casino que se déroule la classe
des enfants
[Musique]
oui oui
les enfants sont encore hésitants
comment ça s'appelle
la plus courante au village
peu à peu le français le créole sont
venus la remplacer dans les discussions
quand je les prends au tout début la
rentrée ben certainement pas
ne comprennent pas très bien la langue
pendant les premiers mois on se ça sera
surtout du vocabulaire qui sera qui sera
enseigné du vocabulaire des phrases les
plus courantes on va dire le souci qu'on
a ici c'est que
la plupart ne seront n'entendent que le
Tania à l'école en fait et c'est ça qui
est problématique on va surtout une
petite chanson
pendant nos
[Musique]
garant de sa langue maternelle Cécile
est heureuse que les enfants se
réapproprient le kalinien et elle reste
en contact régulier avec l'établissement
scolaire
le chef coutumier doit avoir un lien
un lien avec justement l'établissement
pour les problèmes justement d'absence
les problèmes de
certains problèmes il faut absolument
que le chef coutumier est un droit de
regard sur l'éducation des enfants parce
que le chef coutumier c'est Lui qui
connaît toutes les familles des villages
du village
malheureusement
mauvaise nouvelle pour Cécile
[Musique]
mais j'espère que dans
que tout n'est pas perdu j'espère que
après ton départ quand même que les
enfants poursuivront à parler leur
langue avec les parents parce que si ils
continuent plus à parler ça veut dire
que tu n'auras rien fait pour eux
mine de rien c'est vraiment une perte
une perte parce qu'il y a pas de
remplaçant on n'a pas su préparer comme
je parle souvent de la relève on n'a pas
su préparer la relève
assurer la relève c'est ce qu'a voulu
faire ces cils
[Musique]
en quittant l'internat des sœurs après
le collège et en puisant dans ses
économies elle décide de poursuivre son
rêve de petite fille devenir couturière
[Musique]
j'allais à Saint-Laurent prendre mes
coups de couture que j'ai payé moi-même
Jésus rien
une grande couturière
et elle me disait souvent que j'étais
très forte que j'apprenais très très
vite
dans ma couture moi j'aime bien
travailler le coton
et puis déjà c'est dans chez nous comme
il fait chaud c'est mieux
en 1989 Cécile rencontre le futur père
de son fils
quelques années plus tard il est muté à
Alfortville en région parisienne
Cécile le suit ferme son atelier de
couture et prend la direction de l'île
de France
quand nous sommes arrivés en métropole
il fallait quand même un temps de
d'adaptation et c'est vrai que on se
sentait un petit peu je me sentais un
petit peu loin de mon pays de ma famille
de mon atelier de couture que j'ai fermé
les personnes me faisaient ressentir ma
différence en France on connaît on parle
des Amérindiens on voit les Amérindiens
dans la forêt en calembé avec leurs
flèches et que les Américains sont des
sauvages et quand je disais que je viens
de la Guyane ça étonné tout le monde et
ça me donnait quand même de la force de
montrer que nous peuples amérindiens de
la Guyane nous sommes pas des personnes
sauvages nous sommes bien civilisés
comme tout le monde ce choc culturel et
son retour à Bellevue seul avec son fils
vont être déterminants dans son futur
engagement
le village n'a pas bougé la pauvreté est
inquiétante la cause des Amérindiens
devient alors sa bataille
quand j'étais revenu justement c'est
vrai que j'ai voulu renverser belle vie
parce que Bellevue me semblait délaissée
on avait fait une manifestation puisque
autant de pluie nos enfants allaient
justement dans la boue à l'école et moi
ça me plaisait pas du tout
et j'étais pas chef coutumier de les
parler j'étais pas du tout chef coutume
mais j'étais habitant de Bellevue et je
me voyais comme un responsable de si
nous ne disons rien qui va le faire pour
nous aujourd'hui entre son métier de
couturière et sa fonction de chef
coutumière Cécile ne s'accorde que peu
de répit
mon petit cochon ça va mais quand Alvin
son fils sa compagne et leurs deux
enfants viennent lui rendre visite
la priorité
c'est son rôle de grand-mère
c'est de ne pas avoir appris le calinia
à Alvin
aujourd'hui elle se rattrape en
partageant son histoire et ses souvenirs
dans une réunion les habitants avaient
dit nous avons fait le tour du village
du villageois qui peut devenir le chef
de Bel le chef coutumier de Bellevue
et ils avaient dit on avait personne n'a
vu personne par contre
nous proposons nous voulons que ça soit
la petite fille du chef coutumier et il
y a une dame qui était venue vers moi me
disant c'est elle qui doit devenir le
chef du village
je regarde les photos là ça va
je trouve ça beau et c'est dommage que
je n'ai pas de souvenir j'aurais bien
aimé me rappeler et puis aussi
comprendre est assez grand pour
comprendre ce qui se passe parce que
c'était
aujourd'hui avec le recul et puis on m'a
expliqué les choses c'est c'était
historique puisque c'était une première
femme chef
grand gaillard au sourire jovial Alvin
et le fruit du métissage entre sa mère
et son père guadeloupéen l'ancien
compagnon de Cécile
partagez depuis son enfant entre deux
cultures il vit désormais à courroux à
1h15 de ses racines
j'ai l'impression que je devais faire un
choix soit c'était la vie du village ça
c'était la vie
occidentale entre guillemets
et aujourd'hui quand on voit le résultat
je pense avoir plus pris le côté
occidental et
c'est vrai que on est souvent à la
recherche de ses origines quand même
donc on se pose des questions des fois
je me demande si mes ancêtres il
seraient content que je le sois je fasse
le travail que je vais faire enfin sans
manger lève mes enfants moi je vais pas
à l'achat je vais à Super U c'est
de mode de vie différents
mes ancêtres et moi
comme Alvin la jeunesse de Bellevue est
partagée entre deux cultures
je dirais que depuis les allocations
familiales il y a beaucoup de familles
qui ont explosé je ne dis pas que les
allocations familiales ne sont pas
bonnes pas du tout c'est juste pour dire
que avant les allocations familiales les
pères de famille étaient plus fiers et
c'était des hommes fiers des hommes
forts des bons chasseurs des bons
pêcheurs et ils étaient fiers pourquoi
puisque
il s'occupait vraiment de leur famille
et donner un toit à leur famille de les
nourrir par leur par leur efforts et
aujourd'hui
c'est devenu facile c'est devenu facile
puisque on a de l'argent et sans trop
faire d'efforts et c'est aussi ça qui
nous a fait perdre nos valeurs de
travail la terre
les jeunes occupent également leur temps
libre différemment aujourd'hui le
catéchisme ne les attire plus seuls
quelques enfants prennent encore le
temps de passer la porte de la chapelle
et d'autres loisirs voient le jour les
cours de danse moderne séduisent les
jeunes filles
[Musique]
1 2 1 2 1 2 super
les garçons sont curieux mais préfèrent
le football ou se retrouver à la crique
voisine pour décompresser
de vous revoir tout le monde a grandi
mais elle même avec sa grosse barbe
tiraillée entre le monde de leur
grand-parents et celui qu'ils observent
sur les réseaux sociaux les jeunes
Amérindiens sont en manque de repères
[Musique]
comme je comprenais rien du tout j'ai
abandonné parce que je me disais que ça
c'était ça a été faux tu vois tout
d'argent
d'aujourd'hui les jeunes sont intéressés
par l'argent ils savent pas que derrière
il y a des fraudes tout ça il y a les
réseaux et la réalité
que tu bosses
entre rêves et réalité les plus jeunes
sont perdus
Donovan lui a fait le choix de partir du
village pour mieux revenir
un grand voyou le plus grand si
le faux de Bellevue c'était boire fumé
tous les jours du coup je me suis dit il
faut absolument que je parte je partirai
7 ans j'avais envie de lancer mon truc à
moi du coup voilà je suis revenu chez
moi pour lancer pour lancer ce projet ce
sera des activités sur l'eau des balades
sur la rivière expédition un peu de tout
et je dis que ouais il faut il faut
bouger du village pour apprendre autre
chose quoi voir autre chose
nous retrouvons Donovan le lendemain
chez Cécile
il est venu lui parler de son projet
d'expédition en forêt
ça va bien
je suis venu vous voir concernant le
projet alors vous en êtes
oui il y a l'association peuple en
harmonie qui qui est toujours derrière
nous
qui nous suivent voilà
on a été nettoyé un petit peu et on
aimerait bien bien vous emmener
aujourd'hui si possible c'est très bien
de m'inviter si tu peux me donner
quelques minutes je vais ranger mes
affaires bien sûr bien sûr
garant de son projet Cécile accompagne
Donovan depuis trois ans dans ses
démarches administratives
outre son combat pour les terres
l'avenir de la jeunesse du village
continue d'être l'une de ses
préoccupations principales
[Musique]
minutes 10 minutes tranquillement et moi
dans le but c'est de
d'aller tranquillement avec les
touristes de présenter le projet de
partager nos savoirs avec ses clients
directement dans la pirogue se connecter
à la nature
et là on va on va au carber là le
premier Carbet que j'ai fait donc le
carbet de passage le but c'est qu'il
vienne l'après-midi qui passe la nuit
sur place et puis et puis le lendemain
matin direct direction débarcadère et
comme ça on peut être très tôt sur la
rivière
voilà le carbet bienvenue au Carbet
ce sera là que les gens vont dormir les
touristes le but c'est de loger 10
touristes et tout sera fermé au tour
j'ai pris au moins 6 mois six sept mois
pour faire cebbé et voilà c'est un grand
travail ça avance petit à petit c'est
bien l'idée d'avoir fait un carbet parce
que comme ça ça donne envie aux
habitants de refaire un carbet dans leur
cours parce que il est important de
garder cet empreinte là qui nous
appartient
même pas un moment ça fait longtemps
on se proposant d'accompagner les
touristes sur la rivière et en forêt
Donovan espère les faire venir à
Bellevue et donner un nouvel élan au
village et c'est avec son ami coolanon
qu'il a monté ce projet
vous asseoir juste ici
[Musique]
tout ce que je sais
même le simple palmier au hasai c'est
intéressant
avec tous les arbres qui alentourent les
oiseaux qui vont un peu partout
et vivre 24 heures en forêt donc
partager nos savoir-faire c'est
même juste pêcher comme ça à la canne au
filet préparer le poisson ensemble
pourquoi ça fait plaisir de vous emmener
sur la rue
je suis contente parce que ça réveille
en moi beaucoup de choses mon enfance
comme mon papa nous emmenait
[Musique]
un
gibier par exemple pour ça on s'arrêtait
pour pouvoir le récupérer
jusqu'à maintenant parce qu'il y a pas
d'activités
[Musique]
aussi pour la faune parce qu'ici on peut
voir de la montagne des loutres gens des
caïmans
bienvenue au Cancale
ouais au début c'était un petit carré
comme ça et après au fur et à mesure on
a dégagé
et c'est des grands arbres
après 15 minutes sur le fleuve Irak au
bout l'équipage arrive au camp Kala Pana
moustique en calemia
[Musique]
parce que la rivière
avec une petite mise à l'eau qu'on va
faire pour que les gens ils se baignent
en fait c'est de venir avec une grande
pirogue et qui est déjà des canoë à
disposition comme les canaux et ça fait
pas de bruit des gens peuvent naviguer
doucement et surprendre les animaux
et le village il est pas très loin en
fait de ce côté là il est à 2 km
envisager aussi de faire un layon pour
rejoindre le village
super moi je trouve ça très bien puisque
c'est près de la du fleuve du fleuve et
c'est l'idéal c'est l'idéal pour
découvrir justement les arbres tout ce
qu'il y a dans la forêt l'écosystème et
surtout les protéger sur tous les
protéger
c'est bien c'est bien les jeunes c'est
bien
on est les premiers jeunes à lancer
quelque chose au village et
voilà ça ça va donner exemple aux plus
jeunes je suis revenu avec un but au
village à faire revivre ce village et
que les jeunes ne grandissent pas dans
ce que moi j'ai grandi du coup
merci
ça c'est bon c'est naturel
ici c'est important de donner la chef
coutumière c'est c'est grâce à elle
qu'on a eu la valve pour pouvoir
défricher il faut toujours passer par la
chef lorsqu'on a un projet sur le
village c'est comme ça chez nous en fait
c'est on a du respect pour la chef et
tout passe par elle avant de mener à
bien notre projet
ça me rend très fier
comme je dis il faut il faut il faut
croire en eux
pourquoi on est
pour les encourager également
et puis les entendre parler de leur
forêt
de la rivière disons de la nature
moi je trouve ça très bien cela voudrait
dire que depuis tout petit
ils ont appris ils ont appris donc on
leur a transmis que l'amour de la forêt
de la nature
aujourd'hui
concilier les deux la modernité et la
tradition il faut pas dire que la
tradition nous met en arrière non la
tradition no coutume nous croyons se
sont nos richesses nos valeurs nous
avons évolué nous sommes pas restés
derrière on n'est pas derrière il faut
pas croire ce sont des gens qui veulent
pas nous voir avancer devant qui pensent
que nous sommes derrière nous sommes pas
derrière et nous devons être fiers de ce
que nous sommes Carignan de Guyane
donc on peut déclarer cette journée
ouverte à la festivités voilà bonne
journée à tous on tuto au maximum
aujourd'hui est un grand jour
créé en 1994 par l'ONU la Journée
internationale des peuples autochtones
est désormais considéré comme un jour
férié sur la commune d'irakubu
[Musique]
en ce jour de fête Bellevue séparée de
ses plus belles couleurs pour célébrer
la mémoire et l'héritage des Amérindiens
de Guyane
de leur montrer justement nos cultures
ne soient nos savoir-faire notre a
culinaire
montrer aussi que nous comptons
énormément sur la relève demain puisque
nous nous allons pas nous éteindre en
Guyane nous allons exister et nous
résistons et nous résisterons toujours
[Musique]
presque tout le village est présent
artisanat
gastronomie activité pour les plus
jeunes
tout le monde a mis la main à la pâte
dans les regards de la fierté celle de
présenter la richesse de leur communauté
au grand public et de transmettre au
plus jeune une histoire et des valeurs
communes
[Musique]
ça c'est notre identité aussi
un vieux Calignac qui meurt c'est tous
ces savoirs qui risquent de disparaître
avec lui
[Musique]
à 63 ans Cécile se battent encore pour
transmettre cette culture ce patrimoine
qu'elle souhaite voir perdurer après sa
mort
pour la jeunesse de Bellevue pour son
peuple
pour la relever aussi haut que possible
avec la force du Tout Puissant je suis
fier
des habitants de mon village je suis
fier particulièrement de la jeunesse que
j'ai vu évoluer ce soir avec beaucoup de
fierté de dignité et de joie
[Musique]